nous parlons du don du sang ce matin
dans son caddie bonjour richard nadeau
bonjour bonjour toutes celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent vous êtes de la
communication de l'établissement
français du sang antenne de martinique
le ffs qui richard mais noël à sa ble
ment demande aux martiniquais de donner
de leur sang car elle a sa ble ment les
stocks ne sont pas suffisants
effectivement puisque nos besoins en
martinique son quotidien comme partout
ailleurs sur le territoire
nous avons besoin de 60 dons par jour
pour faire face aux besoins de nos
malades
effectivement nous tournons plutôt dans
les 20 à 25 dons par jour
donc effectivement il est l' urgence et
depuis depuis la mi janvier
comme expliqué que ces stocks ne sont
jamais à flot alors ils ne sont jamais à
faux parce que effectivement les gens ne
sont pas toujours au rendez vous parce
que effectivement on n'a pas toujours le
temps de venir donner mais comme je le
disais derrière et bien l'église
les opérations sont programmées les
besoins sont là et donc derrière ben
nous sommes obligés à lhassa blement de
répéter nos messages d'inviter chaque
jour les donneurs à venir en commune sur
la maison du don à venir faire don de
leur sang
la réalité des chiffres et puisque vous
avez dit qu'il faut 60 poche par jour ce
qui devrait équivaloir combien la
combine d'honneur de notre île sur des
chiffres très très moyen alors un
donneur pouvant sommes en tout cas
pouvoir donner 6 x 6 fois par an une
femme quatre fois par an aujourd'hui
nous tournons à peu près sur 8 entre
8000 et 9000 d'honneur qui viennent
entre majorité vient une fois par an
donner son sang mais il nous faudra à
peu près 15 millions par an sur l'année
dernière nous avons fait à peu près 9700
n'approche les 10 mille mais
effectivement il ya encore un produit
sanguin sur quatre qui vient de la
solidarité nationale et combien ça coûte
de faire venir une poche de sang partie
est bien avec les fred approche tout le
monde sait les frais qu'on peut avoir à
faire venir de france mais c'est pas
forcément une question de coût c'est
surtout une question de délai puisque
sur certains produits comme les
concentrés plaquettaire qui ont une
durée de vie de cinq jours on sait bien
des cons il nous faut une journée pour
le prélever en france par exemple le
temps de le faire venir une journée à
deux jours il nous reste plus que deux
jours pour le maintenir pour nos malades
et donc là ça devient véritablement
critique donc c'est plus une question de
on va dire de temps pour le faire venir
et puis je n'oublie pas bien sur les
risques majeurs dont on peut koné
comptes dont on peut connaître bien sûr
les aléas les impacts sur notre île
alors des cantiques ont tous leur
richard nadeau pourquoi ne donne-t-on
pas davantage les campagnes par exemple
lorsque vous faites un appel est-ce que
les campagnes sont suffisamment
pertinente suffisamment concernante pour
le grand public
alors le nom et ton toujours anonyme
bénévole et volontaire ne peut pas
forcer les gens à donner
donc ce sont simplement des campagnes
d'incitation après ce qui peut nous
manque effectivement sur notre
territoire ce sont des relais notamment
en commune
et puis dans le milieu associatif parce
que je rappelle quand même que
l'établissement français du sang est
avant tout un préleveur et que 100 200
et le soutien et le relais dans la
population mais nous sommes là avec le
camion à attendre que le donneur arrive
est ce que vous attendez par
l'association le soutien du monde
associatif
vous aimeriez avoir des associations
spécialisées dans dans cette récolte
dans ses appels à la générosité soient
concernés sont des associations
spécialisées il peut y en avoir des
associations de donneurs de sang
bénévoles il en existe quelques jeunes
en martinique hélas pas assez mais
aujourd'hui nous travaillons beaucoup
avec des associations de culturel
cultuel la mc les clubs auto les clubs
service rotary england club
par exemple pour ne pas les citer
kiwanis donc on a déjà eu il ya beaucoup
d'associations qui nous aide mais
effectivement sans elle ce sera encore
beaucoup plus difficile mais on en a
besoin de plus et d'initiative peut être
personnel aussi pour arriver à motiver
les gens commune à venir faire leurs
premiers dons et à venir les faire après
les dans les mois qui suivent vous
aimeriez par exemple que de grands clubs
sportifs s'associe à cette opération de
récolte de dons par exemple la gauloise
de trinité par exemple le golden star à
fort de france ou bien lille olympique
du marin je sais pas oui exactement même
si c'est une fois par an une fois tous
les deux ans alors généralement nous
avons déjà eu à mener ce genre
d'opération avec ces clubs
alors forcément le jour de l'événement
sportif c'est pas le meilleur moment
mais effectivement au moins pour les
sensibiliser et puis après dés que nous
revenons dans la commune par exemple et
bien avoir les sportifs et surtout les
familles les accompagnants qui viennent
et bien faire don de leur sang ou voir
au moins comment ça se passe on peut
donner son sang à partir de quel âge à
partir de 18 ans les communicants
devrait être capable de s'adapter
d'adapter le message pour inciter à
venir alors adapter message oui alors
comment l'adapter parce que c'est vrai
que c'est nous c'est là c'est la
question de l'urgence c'est dire que
nous comme quand vous nous entendez
effectivement c'est vraiment que les
choses ont mal parce que sinon nous
pourrions communiqué tous les jours
exactement mais on pourrait être là
encore plus souvent
effectivement nous essayons à chaque
fois de ne pas non plus fatigués les
gens mais effectivement c'est tous les
jours dont nous aurions besoin de deux
coups de main et beaucoup de gens nous
donnent des coups de main aussi tous les
jours nous avons déjà des bénévoles en
sur la lassitude du message par exemple
de l'appel aux dons
alors on essaie d'avoir des degrés dans
le message important et urgent et puis
surtout de monter des opérations qu'ils
soient un petit peu plus comme dire
convivial comme je pense à un noctambus
gens pensent à la journée mondiale des
donneurs de sang
je pense à par exemple les conducteurs
100% responsable
ce sont des opérations qui permettent de
faire un petit pas de côté par rapport
au don de sang et traiter d'autres
sujets mais d'être toujours dans la
problématique effectivement des produits
sanguins et le public du donneur de sang
le profil du donneur type au profit du
donneur type c'est quelqu'un qui est
déjà installé dans sa vie qui peut être
disponible en journée pour venir donner
ce que nous il nous faut quand même une
demi journée pour fabriquer à partir
d'un don un produit sanguin je rappelle
que l'établissement français du sang ne
fait pas collectés mais fabrique aussi à
partir des dombes des martiniquais les
produits sanguins pour la population
donc il nous faut quand même un petit
temps de travail donc on c'est pour ça
qu'on ne peut pas collecter n'importe
quoi non plus et bien tout là toute la
journée ça va être des donneurs qui sont
plutôt salariés ça va être
principalement des femmes parce que les
hommes ont peur des piqûres
ça va être effectivement des gens qui
sont bien assez de leur vie et qui qui
peuvent prendre ce petit temps 7 petites
heures nécessaires pour venir nous aider
à sauver des vies
vous savez quoi je me souviens de me
retrouver parfaitement dans ce que vous
venez de dire les hommes ont peur de
donner du style ont peur de la piqûre
sépare c'est par là qu'on aurait dû
commencer c'est la crête de l'éguille de
se faire piquer la peau tout simplement
exactement en tout cas c'est ce que les
hommes nous disent est ce que c'est ce
que les femmes nous disent aussi donc
nous disent que les hommes ont peur des
piqûres mais bon ça elles les
connaissent sans doute mieux que nous
mais effectivement à partir de là des
moments où la piqûre est mise en avant à
la peur de la piqûre c'est difficile
pour nous de passer au delà juste à
rassurer les gens et en leur proposant
de venir voir et surtout d'en parler
avec les donneurs les donneuses qu'ils
connaissent autour de voir arriver à
dédramatiser cette petite seconde où sa
pince un peu épuisant mais deux c'est
comme on n'a pas réussi à monter cette
montée d'adrénaline lié au fait que
l'aiguillé rentrer dans la peau une fois
que c'est fait c'est fini et voilà alors
c'est qu'on ne peut pas mettre non plus
n'importe quoi sur la peau avant de
piquer
mais c'est vrai que nous essayons de
faire comprendre aux gens que cette
petite cette minuscule douleur n'est
rien par rapport aux besoins et surtout
bien fait aux bienfaits que nous
arrivons à procurer aux gens que nous
arrivons à soigner c'est quand même
trois mille personnes par an donc
qu'est-ce qu'une petite piqûre quand on
sait que dans l'eau dans nos
associations dans nos églises dans nos
bourgs dans le quartier il ya des gens
dans nos familles qui sont toujours
debout
grâce à cette générosité quelles sont
les craintes persistantes dans le don du
sang c'est ya un risque pour le donneur
risques pour celui qui reçoit les
maladies contenu ou non dans le sens je
pense qu'il a surtout déjà peut-être une
mauvaise compréhension des
contre-indications temporaires notamment
puisque notons on en parlait récemment
propos du tatouage
les gens pensent qu'on ne peut pas
donner parce qu'on est à tous et c'est
faux on peut donner si on est tatoué
simplement il ya des petites
contre-indication temporaire on va vous
demander un petit délai simplement et
les gens se souviennent plus tôt du fait
qu'ils ne peuvent pas donner du pourquoi
on ne peut pas donner
donc c'est plutôt un galiègue compagnie
de son sens non plus bas des moments on
est revenu en martinique on attend
quatre mois et on peut donner ouais donc
ce n'est pas un problème mais après
effectivement le tout c'est à nous
établissements d'arriver à faire passer
ce message là sensibiliser toujours plus
les jeunes et la population est leur
dire que le geste est facile il suffit
simplement d'attendre le bon moment et
il y aura toujours un bon moment alors
lorsque je donne mon sang est ce que je
transmets comme ça pèle mêle je
transmets mon diabète mon cholestérol
mais maladies sexuellement
transmissibles je suis plus trop croire
encore à travers le sens où bien ou bien
où l'alcool par exemple ou bien encore
puisqu'on en parle beaucoup en ce moment
puisque on a dit que 95 % de la
population est contaminée par la
molécule de chlordécone est ce qu'il ya
un risque pour la personne qui reçoit
avec tout ce que je voulais c'était par
exemple
non non non il n'y a pas de risque pour
la personne qui reçoit notamment bat
déjà d'une part parce que nous avons les
garde-boue fallait garde-fous plutôt
qu'ils sont qui sont mis en place le
principe de précaution fait que
effectivement avec les
contre-indications temporaire on arrive
à limiter les risques à l'entrée ensuite
effectivement comme je disais nous
fabriquons les produits sanguins donc
nous menons une batterie de tests qui
nous permet d'évacuer
effectivement tous ces risques là et
parce que effectivement la personne qui
attend le produit sanguin est déjà entre
la vie et la mort il n'y a pas de
transfusion de confort donc on ne peut
pas transfusé n'importe quoi donc on
nous faisons tout
faisons attention et nous prenons toutes
ses précautions lorsqu'on a été
transfusé est-ce qu'on devienne
d'honneur parce qu'on a pris conscience
de quelque chose
nous aimerions bien hélas le problème
c'est que toujours avec le principe de
précaution quand vous avez été
transfusés pour l'instant vous ne pouvez
pas encore donner votre sang il y a nous
essayons de faire évoluer les textes en
ce sens là pour que vous puissiez
revenir aux dons mais effectivement
quand on a été transfusé bien on ne peut
pas donner parce que simplement après ça
on a des risques si on trouve des si on
trouve des désinfections ça peut poser
des problèmes par la suite
la religion peut être un frein à cet
acte de don oui fin certaine en tout cas
il ya certains cultes en martinique que
nous connaissons qui sont qui ne qui ne
veulent pas donner et puis qu'ils sont
assez virulents contre le bon sens mais
en général que ce soit les adventistes
des évangélistes tout le monde donne en
martinique
c'est vraiment une petite portion des
cultes qui refuse de donner alors on
voit souvent dans le camion de
l'établissement français du sang sur les
parkings des centres commerciaux vous
avez également cette maison du don au
chu à l'hôpital pierre zobda-quitman
mais finalement c'est peut-être là le
prouve que le problème se pose
il est quand même effectivement pour y
aller c'est la croix et la bannière
effectivement le site et pas forcément
très bien placé et encore on sait
effectivement que c'est un endroit fait
tout ce qui est chateauboeuf notamment
et échangeurs sont en service et qui
très embouteillé c'est un incident qui
est là depuis quand même plusieurs
années plusieurs dizaines d'années nous
avons essayé de le faire changer
d'endroit ça n'a pas été possible
effectivement nous avons déjà changé les
horaires il ya il ya quelques semaines
encore pour essayer de faciliter l'accès
à la maison du don mais effectivement
c'est un placement qui n'est pas évident
maintenant il a aussi des avantages
il est beaucoup plus confortable que le
camion est l'avantagé aussi d'être
ouvert six jours par semaine et
notamment les après midi et le samedi
matin
donc tout ce que nous pouvons faire
c'est d'inviter les gens qui sont au
moins dans le secteur de chez le cheikh
fort-de-france et lamentin de venir
donner au moins quand ils en ont le
temps / / / la maison du don mais
effectivement c'est d'abord et avant
tout les collectant commune qui
fonctionne merci richard met dos de la
communication de l'établissement
français du sang remercie d'avoir été
avec nous depuis on espère surtout
qu'avant le carnaval
il y aura beaucoup
de martinique et qui auront donné leur
sang car ces précieux pour la vie merci
merci à vous